he's Kirk D cousins the Vikings
quarterback and that's a big big win
against New Orleans over the weekend and
kind enough to join us how you feeling
today I'm feeling good
lost my voice yelling in the Superdome
yesterday but doing well and now we got
a short week and the teams don't get an
easier from here I was wondering about
that on the game-winning drive how loud
it was because I could hear you like you
were yelling like how loud was it trying
to call a play yeah that was the loudest
game I've ever played in college pro
comment played in Seattle three times
played in the Superdome multiple times
before that but for whatever reason that
was just different it was louder after
the first drive of the game I was
regretting that we hadn't used the
silent cadence under center Hall in
practice all week because I was
screaming and my voice cracked a bunch
like a high schooler so I was just
screaming at top of my lungs and and it
was just different than any other game I
played him you weren't looking at
anybody else other than Kyle Rudolph so
I'm assuming that that play was designed
for him well you know based on a
defensive look and with it with the
all-out blitz they brought the ball had
to go to him obviously with other other
looks you know it would have been
different but all went to him and at
that point it's just uh you know mano a
mano
one-on-one and the ball goes up and you
hope your guy can go get the rebound and
he certainly did what did you think when
now they obviously review all scoring
plays but then they were looking at pass
interference yeah with the way the game
had gone I expected it to be he didn't
get two feet in or he didn't complete
the catch or there was pass interference
and we're gonna have a ten minute review
and I asked I was expecting so I
actually you know went over the sideline
and sat down on the bench thinking that
they were going to take ten minutes to
talk about it and then Kevin Stefanski
came over after about 20 seconds and
said Kirk we we won the game and I
looked up and I looked up and saw that
you know it looked like the post game
scene so I thought alright that's good
enough for me
so it was it was certainly a unique
ending do you understand it pass
interference any better this year the
you did last year you know I do think
that the ability to in a really crucial
moment go back and look at it has proved
invaluable this year
there have been a couple times where
I've been glad that Coach Zimmer has
been able to throw a flag to at least
try to get it right if there's a chance
to but there's been other times where
you know we didn't challenge and I would
have liked it or it just proves
ridiculous a little bit when there
really wasn't enough to go off of but
we're gonna take five to ten minutes
talk about it but all in all you know it
hasn't changed a lot but I don't know
that it's made it a lot worse either you
gave us you like that then the post game
the locker room speech you gave the the
fans and teammates what they wanted
when's the first time you use that
expression you like that it started when
I was my roommate Tom Canty and played
for the Jets this year we were roommates
together in Washington before I got
married and we would say it to each
other just joking around whatever we did
we'd say oh you love that or you like
that and and I you know he looked at me
and be like yeah I do so what but
somehow it just morphed into that one
game you know when we had to come back
against the Buccaneers in 2015 and I
knew that you know a lot of people
didn't think I belong to the quarterback
and and so when we want it just felt
like validation or vindication and I
just said you know you may not like me
but you like that and and it just kind
of took off from there I guess because
of social media and you haven't really
played do it much sense don't really
need to but I guess yesterday's game it
just kind of came out again did you
trade market we did years ago but I
think to keep the trade mark you have to
prove use of it and we certainly haven't
put it to use a lot so I don't know if
that's even a valid trade mark anymore
wait wait you put it to use over the
weekend I guess so but from a business
standpoint which is why you trade market
I haven't done a lot with it so I
probably couldn't couldn't keep the
trade mark what was the house like when
you got back home yeah you know my boys
were asleep but it was great to get home
and all my wife was on cloud nine
and uh that's life in the NFL I mean it
is every single week you know certainly
in the playoffs but even the regular
season it's it's the highest of highs
the lowest of lows if you win or lose
and you know when you get back to your
phone after the game and you got 200
text messages well you know it's it's
fun it's special and you just remind of
all the people in your life who are not
just watching but they're really in your
corner and cheering you on there are
certain players in certain sports where
it doesn't matter what they do during
the regular season it's about the
postseason and you're one of those
quarterbacks it doesn't you know Tony
Romo was like this that that you're
almost like the newer version of Tony
Romo where it's like okay great regular
season good regular season but it is a
complement to you because we we want to
wait to see what you do in a big moment
is that you've faced all of that
criticism and even now after that win
against that team in that building now
you're gonna still have people say okay
but can he do it in San Francisco I'm
the only one I mean I was talking to
Troy Aikman before the game this week
and said you know the fact that you know
when you guys were playing there's a
49ers you played that entire season it
really didn't matter what your records
were everybody expected the 49ers and
Cowboys to be in the NFC Championship
game and that was pretty much going to
define the entire year who won that game
so I said it's got to be tough you know
to play you know you know 17 18 games
and you can be 18 and one but if you
don't beat the 49ers and Steve Young the
season was a failure so you know that's
that's life in the big city that's
professional sports in general and you
know America loves winners so whoever
standing at the end and there's only one
team you know that's the one that gets
celebrated just about everybody else
walks away feeling like they left
something on the table it felt like in
the moment and even the the analysts
were saying the biggest throw of your
career was the one to Thielen in
overtime would you say you agree well
you know certainly what I'm dropping
back and making the throw I don't feel
that but but then when you step back and
you understand the importance like you
just said of the playoffs and late in
the year and that kind of a thing um you
know certainly the outside world it
carries more weight but
you know from my perspective there were
there were a lot of other throws along
the way that mean just as much well
Congrats wrest the voice there are you
gonna be working on the silent count
this week yeah you know we'll be right
back at it in another hostile
environment so we've got - like you said
you know work on the silent count and
have a plan I mean they're they're the
number one seed for a reason and we'll
have our hands full and you know they
only lost three games and all three of
them came down to I think the final play
so it's going to be a fun one you know
it's it's what a NFL playoffs are all
about Kirk thank you congratulations all
right thanks guys lucky to you Ben
Stuckart D cousins Vikings quarterback
for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]